Do I say it cheesy? The explorer in all of us!
and then we play the classical version of
the class course games intro.
Somebody's pursuits relate to an
overarching goal or story and others
don't
oh sorry and Andre burnt his lunch
actually play the game
[laughs] Yes.
Minecraft is the epitome of a sandbox game
[laughs] It's not 'eh-pi-tohme'?
'Eh-pi-tuh-mi'?
I honestly don't think I've ever seen it written
The epitome. [laughs]
While you might get similar results...hmmm...
With interchangeable game carntriges--interchangeable game cartridges
First handheld console with interchangeable game cartrages
*random stuff*
And the Gameboy wasn't exactly the most technologically advanced handheld on the market
with its blurry screen and -- woah, woah, woah
[laughs] -- sub-par graphics?!
woah, that's nasty talk!
Bundling the system with the incredible, popular Tetris probably helped too
and by 'probably' I mean 'YEAH.'
That is kind of funny though, it's like "we have a color screen and a portable TV"
"We've got Tetris..." AHHHHH!
yes yes keep it going running gag
running gag whenever you're ready
oh you're even filming has been acting
stupid on-camera great don't want that
dumb this document all right you ready
and I just revealed that I said
something stupid
great the thing is gonna be okay right
I'm gonna keep doing it
I want to keep doing it fancy talk fair
your ace 2x and nearly 360 degrees of
controller controller Fifita hello i
read these all the way through but
living
the moment when I actually record them
this thing I read that's actually the
script later we should put in the script
he got a contract with NBC everything
what I got but I was hard to read
because I'm like what you haven't gotten to simalar ranks yei
the more rights yet
ya better as a simple top and pac-man
and the video and probably an America
was somebody make the game show they
took radio and television at face value
today we call that the internet [laughs]
haha that's pretty profound yes me
please i have tried to sell it is that
it allows you to immerse yourself in the
game by literally taking on the role of
your character and then a car shows up
and completely ruin your marketing
experience demonstrative or the battle
game is your standard bar fro Bob bar
for bar for who and I don't like the
monster ship or the battle game is your
standard buffer Lok Lak Holly
demonstrative or the battle game is your
standard buffer large bar offer large
food input ring that plural kind of
nerdy working away here lord of the ring
as lady Stark writer of leaving mode
mundania up [laughs] i did got at bars
aren't allowing fantasy world go away
we're talking about working here there's
no fast and furious LARPing yet yeah if
it will beget human can get addicted to
gambling in the same way to get addicted
to cigarettes alcohol and cook for
cocaine-related credit cigarettes
alcohol or choake we believe that you
are consciously or intentionally selling
products the kids
yes by the way here's the new pokemon
everybody how to share your your ps4
games with your friends and it's just
two guys and one guy had a disk and he
gave it to the other guy and that was it
[laughter]
you've come a long way from the first
cutscene impact man why why why are you
driving it's Sunday you give me trap
yesterday about what you gotta make this
Sega joke 50 more times and every
single time we mention board games you
just seemed like slide which makes it better in monopoly
because I know what to get you for your
birthday mail coach gonna bring you so
many monopoly bring it by every version
are you ready for some call of duty haha
but we got street fighter 5 let's get
the party started on the Friday night
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next blank